il a quitté ma maison le jour des deux pauses les
poignets j'ai mal aux
jambes j'ai mal aux mains j'ai des crampes
tu as juste mal partout quand tu rentres à
la maison
tu ne veux rien faire d'autre que
dormir
de choses doivent être
changées parce qu'il
est facile de se faire virer pour ce qui se passe
là-bas, vous
savez donc nous essayons de faire une
différence
[Musique]
vous recevrez tous beaucoup de SMS d'
Amazon et ils vous diront  pour voter non
et ils vous diront
comment voter non, ils mettront en place différentes
personnes qui ont travaillé là-bas et diront eh
bien un tel a
travaillé là-bas et ils adorent ça donc vous
devriez voter non pour le syndicat
[Musique]
mais  en ce moment, je pense qu'ils sont
nerveux à l'idée
que si les travailleurs ici réussissent,
cela se répandra dans tout le pays
et je pense que tout le monde ici
devrait savoir qu'en europe, euh,
amazon traite avec les syndicats et s'ils peuvent
traiter avec les syndicats
en europe, c'est sûr que l'enfer  peut traiter
avec les syndicats aux États-Unis d'
Amérique
[Musique]
vous